I wanted to create a video on the
cholesterol myth simply because it's
been so brainwashed into our heads from
1950 more than any other myth that has
been in existence Ancel keys in 1950
researcher did this huge study to
correlate all these countries that got
he wanted to study different countries
in relationship to how many of them had
heart disease and and what they ate if
they were fat so he studied in half a
dozen countries and this is what he came
up with in a thumbnail sketch he found
that we have heart attacks here and we
have fat consumption here and he found
that these countries the more fat that
they consumed the more heart attacks
that they got so then he was kind of
like the father of the lipid heart
attack theory and he was untime magazine
and from there on out it kind of went
south and it's just been brainwashed
into our minds but here's a couple
little things he basically kind of
altered the information just a little
bit here's two simple facts that he
manipulated the study wasn't done with a
half a dozen countries it was done with
22 countries and he left out the
countries who ate a lot of fat and had
low heart disease okay so these
countries Norway and Holland he left
those out okay and there was other ones
as well and then he also left out the
countries who ate low fat that had high
amounts of heart attacks like Chile now
if you include all of the data and the
study it pretty much looks like this
okay it doesn't give you any data it
doesn't show any statistical
significance of people that eat
saturated fat actually have increased
cholesterol or people that have
increased cholesterol showed any
increase in heart disease in fact you
want to know how many studies in the
world that we're done that actually
showed a relationship between these zero
none of them can
now that the way they wanted so what
they do with any other researcher would
do is basically manipulate the data and
make it look make it a line to what
their theory is so they can you know
obviously get more grants but the point
is that there is no study that shows
this relationship here and it's
basically the greatest scam of the
century so let's go into a little bit
more about what HDL is and LDL you've
heard HDL being good cholesterol and LDL
being bad cholesterol well it's not even
cholesterol what does it stand for
high-density lipoproteins low-density
lipoproteins those are proteins they're
not even cholesterol they're envelopes
that carry cholesterol through the body
so the HDL so-called good cholesterol
carries the old cholesterol to the liver
to be recycled okay now why is our body
recycle cholesterol if it's so bad why
does it recycle well the fact is it's
not bad and we need cholesterol our
bodies make 2,000 milligrams of
cholesterol every single day near every
single cell and your body makes
cholesterol an egg would be 300
milligrams of cholesterol the truth is
that when you eat more eat less
cholesterol your body just makes more of
it because it acts as a band-aid to help
arteries that are corroding or getting
ulcers or getting damaged or getting
inflammation it acts to help as a
healing agent and that's why cholesterol
is in the artery because it's trying to
heal it as a scab it's not the culprit
it's the middleman most of our brains
are made from cholesterol to allow for
the insulation to travel with the nerves
we have all the cell walls are made from
cholesterol most of our hormones are
made from cholesterol especially the sex
ones so we need this cholesterol
desperately in order to survive if you
didn't have cholesterol you wouldn't be
able to survive and cholesterol is also
needed to make vitamin D to help convert
and increase the calcium into the blood
so then we can take the other vitamins
to transport into the bone
I've watched that video on vitamin k2
because that's very important but
because it tells you the other half of
the story with clogged arteries so we
have this good cholesterol which carries
all cholesterol to the liver recycles it
that means it's good and then the bad
cholesterol carries cholesterol from the
liver into the tissues okay but they're
really not bad they're just trance
they're envelopes to transport calcium
back and forth out of the LDL only a
very small part of the LDL is really
really bad and it's the very small
little particles because an LDL there's
a lot of different there's different
sizes you have these big fluff balls and
you've got these tiny little pebbles of
LDL and the real small ones are the ones
that form the plaquing around and inside
the tin inside the artery itself and
that's why people are against them but
the purpose is the body's is trying to
heal itself so now let's talk about what
is the problem with heart attacks
okay well it's inflammation it's
inflammation because the wall of the
artery is damaged from inflammation and
it's kind of like an ulcer it's a
degenerative type situation and that's
why the cholesterol and the calcium
comes in then to help heal it and then
that's the clogging factor so what
causes inflammation sugar okay sugar is
the big culprit sugar is very
inflammatory and the amount of sugar
that we eat not only will spike
cholesterol and triglycerides because
the body's trying to heal the damaged
arteries but it will clog up your
arteries more than anything and so and
that includes the whole grains that the
doctors are telling you it's okay or the
government whatever so it comes down the
sugar so the problem is not the fat it's
the sugar okay so that's interesting the
other thing that causes inflammation is
having an adrenal problem as well
because your adrenal gland secretes
cortisol and cortisol is a natural
anti-inflammatory but when you lose that
affect you end up with inflammation in
the body but in a thumbnail sketch you
don't have to be afraid of class
draw anymore you can go ahead and
consume cholesterol I've been eating
four eggs every single day for the last
20 years my cholesterol is about 160 170
160 which is totally normal and lastly I
want to tell you something we're how do
you increase the good cholesterol to
increase good cholesterol you have to
consume egg yolks butter and cheese
that's right egg yolks butter and cheese
especially from grass-fed cows will
increase the good cholesterol okay what
increases bad cholesterol sugar and junk
food okay so I hope that helped a little
bit unbraid wash you with this
cholesterol myth but and I want to leave
you if there's one more thing
IQ or having a high high IQ does not
equal sanity just because someone is
so-called educated doesn't mean they're
sane all right I'll see you the next
video